imaginez des chevaux en liberté galoper
sur d'immenses étendues sauvages
imaginez maintenant que ces chevaux
soient poursuivis par un hélicoptère à
bord de sniper il visent les chevaux du
groupe et les tuent
tous en fait tout ça c'est bien réel et
ça se passe loin des caméras c'est même
soutenu et organisé par un gouvernement
mais ça fait polémique salut c'est
lucade brut nature quand j'ai découvert
cette pratique j'ai été très étonné et
même assez choqué en creusant un peu
j'ai pu voir qu'il y avait eu des
pétitions et des rassemblements pour
tenter de stopper ces tirs par
hélicoptère mais j'ai aussi découvert
des pétitions et des rassemblement pour
soutenir leur mise en
[Musique]
place et en fait derrière ces chevaux il
y a toute une histoire ils n'ont pas
toujours été là ce dimanche dans ce
nouvel épisode de la grande explication
j'ai voulu comprendre ce qu'il y avait
derrière ces abattages massifs de
chevaux d'où viennent ces chevaux et
qu'est-ce qu'on leur reproche pourquoi
les abattre par hélicoptère et quels
sont les arguments pour et contre je
vous
explique alors petite précision avant de
commencer dans cette vidéo on a essayé
de limiter et de flouter au maximum les
images un peu difficiles afin que cette
histoire puisse être vue par le plus
grand nombre cette histoire elle se
passe en Australie et plus précisément
ici dans l'état de nouvelle gale du Sud
les chevaux dont on parle ce sont eux on
les appelle aussi les Brumbies fin
octobre 2023 Penny sharp la ministre de
l'Environnement de nouvelle gale du Sud
annonce que ses chevaux vont de nouveau
être abattus par hélicoptère dans cet
état et ça alors même que ça avait été
officiellement stoppé pendant plus de 20
ans mais cette décision elle est aussi
très soutenu notamment par des
scientifiques comme Maggie
Watson
je vais donc essayer de vous présenter
ces chevaux et de vous résumer les
débats pas si simples qu'ils entraînent
mais d'abord voyons concrètement en quoi
consistent ces
[Musique]
abattages nous sommes en
1984 dans un hélicoptère quelque part en
Australie cette scène qui peut rappeler
des classiques de film de guerre c'est
en fait un abattage de dizaines de
chevaux dans ce cas-là ce sont des
éleveurs qui cherchent à éviter la
transmission de maladie entre des
chevaux et leur troupau alors oui ce
n'est ni le même endroit ni le même
contexte que les abattages dont on parle
aujourd'hui mais ça vous montre un peu
le principe en fait je n'ai trouvé
presque aucune image des abattages plus
récents vu les polémiques autour du
sujet les autorités évitent de
communiquer les dates et les lieux de ce
type d'opération j'ai donc demander à
cette scientifique en quoi consiste la
technique qui doit être utilisée
aujourd'hui
par hélicoptère il av été interdit dans
cet état depuis l'an 2000 cette anné
dans cet endroit le parc national Dex
River environ 600 chevaux sont avecette
[Musique]
technique
lyed comingossers of dead horses and
more that areured
slowly des chevx ser pas instantané ce
qui aurait occasionné des souffrances
l'épo le nombre exa de chevaux concern
n' pas pu tre déterminé mais ça
déclenché une grande polémique et ça
débouché sur l'interdiction de cette
pratique
si ces abattages ont été réautorisés en
nouvelle gale du Sud c'est pour tuer des
milliers de chevaux dans cet endroit
dont on n pas encore parlé tout ça je
vais vous le présenter un peu plus tard
mais il faut se replonger d'abord un peu
dans l'histoire de ces brumbees car j'ai
découvert qu'à la base ces chevaux ils
étaient
domestiques cette carte elle montre la
présence des chevaux en Australie avant
le 18e siècle vous ne voyez rien et ben
c'est normal parce que les chevaux
n'existaient tout simplement pas sur
cette grande île isolée et voici une
carte des chevaux en l'an
2000 lors de la dernière grande
estimation nationale faite par des
scientifiques australiens le nombre de
chevaux il est alors estimé à 400000 à
travers tout le pays c'est tout
simplement la plus grande population de
chevaux en liberté dans le monde alors
comment on est passé de ça à ça en à
peine plus de 200 ans à partir de 1788
les premiers colons europé débar et
s'installle en Australie ce sont ces
premières flottes qui apportent les
premiers
chevaux that came bought more before the
motor car you needed a horse anything to
go to shopping for police work
for la suite je vous la fais rap au f à
mesure des anné de plus en plus de
chevaux sont relâchés dans la nature et
dans ce pays isolé qui n'a connu aucun
chevau jusqu'à présent il se multiplie
assez
rapidement en parallèle ils deviennent
progressivement des symboles culturels
assez important pour toute une partie
des
Australiens children stories so people
deliberately go into the park to try and
find wild horsesuse it makes them feel
so much better
within seeing the wild horses surviving
on their own without human intervention
donc pour résumer des chevaux il y en a
aujourd'hui un peu partout en Australie
et ils sont déjà abattus dans certains
États mais aujourd'hui puis le débat se
cristallise notamment dans un état en
particulier la nouvelle gale du Sud où
comme on l'a dit les tirs avaient été
interdits et viennent d'être réautorisé
on va voir pourquoi le lieu concerné
c'est plus précisément le parc national
de kossusco le plus grand parc de cet
état il est situé dans ce qu'on appelle
les Alpes australiennes alors oui moi
aussi quand j'ai lu ça j'ai pensé à ces
Alpes là mais rien à voir on est bien en
Australie et c'est la plus haute chaîne
de montagne du pays reprenons l'histoire
des chevaux ce parc national de
cososusco si on reprend prend les
estimations du gouvernement il abrite
moins de 2000 chevaux dans les années
2000 ce nom passe ensuite autour de 5000
avant d'augmenter fortement pour
atteindre entre 14500 et 23500 chevaux
en
2022 20 ans plus tard il y aurait donc
entre 7 et 20 fois plus de chevaux et
cette tendance à la hausse
s'accélérer
comme vous venez de l'entendre les
estimations des autorités sont remises
en cause par certains opposants et
notamment Jill pckring qui reconnaît
néanmoins une possible augmentation
d'autres organisations australiennes
notamment scientifiques soutiennent la
méthode utilisée et partagent l'analyse
sur la tendance ce rapport rent du Sénat
australien indique peu importe quel est
le nombre exact de chevaux aujourd'hui
nous avons des preuves claires d'une
tendance à la hausse qui doublera ce
nombre dans un avenir proche ok mais
pourquoi cette augmentation ça pourrait
selon certains justifier d'en abattre
des milliers par
[Musique]
hélicoptère ces photos ont été prises
dans le parc de kusco elle montre des
transformations provoquées par la
présence des
chevaux like smothering the land to
persuade people that these horses nice
as they are to look at are terrible in a
national park so all of the soils and
all of the environments evolved without
hooved animals and so a Hoof is a very
sharp thing it digs into the ground and
so when you go into areas that have a
lot of of horses um you can see there's
there's trails um where they've crushed
the vegetation and there's some really
on the Foures of freshwayfish that I
work with they need really clear fast
flowing water and when you push all of
that dirt and mud
into selon le comité scientifique des
espèces menacées ces perturbations
pourra même contribuer à la disparition
totale de certaines espèces de plantes
ou d'animaux locaux selon eux c'est par
exemple de ces 12 animaux vertébrés
comme ces lézards comme ce rat comme ces
poissons Galaxia ou ces grenouilles
corobories c'est pour ces raisons que
l'état de nouvelle gale du Sud a décidé
de recourir au tir par hélicoptère pour
diminuer la population de ces chevaux et
ils sont prêts en mettre les moyens
selon le Conseil des espèces invasives
le coût de cette technique est estimé en
moyenne à 85 dollars australiens par
cheval ce qui voudrait dire plus d'un
million au total le plan actuel il vise
à limiter le nombre de chevaux à 3000
d'ici 2 7 contre500 à 2500 actuellement
selon les autorités comme on l'a dit
tout à
l'heure
elle demande notamment d'effectuer des
comptages précis pour voir si les
abattages de chevaux aident réellement
les espèces menacées ou non de son côté
le rapport du Sénat conclut les impact
négatif démontrable et visible de la
population actuelle et sa tendance à la
hausse justifie une action
urgente
je suis alors demandé si en admettant
qu'il faille réduire le nombre de
chevaux il n'y avait pas des techniques
alternatives à
[Musique]
l'abattage revenons fin octobre 2023
quand l'état de nouvelle gale du Sud
annonce le retour de ses abattages par
hélicoptère l'organisation de Jil
pckring l'Australien brumby alliance se
dit consterné par cette décision elle
met en avant plusieurs autres
solution remotely trigger the gate to
close and then they sell them to the
public we say you use fertility control
which is D and that stops them producing
FS for between 2 and years depending on
the serum they use
selon le rapport du Sénat le relogement
n'est pas suffisant pour faire baisser
la population et les techniques de
stérilisation ne seraient pas assez
efficac à cette échelle si on reprend
les données du gouvernement voici le
nombre de chevaux qu'il aurait fallu
retirer du parc pour limiter
l'augmentation de la population ce
nombre c'est uniquement pour stopper la
croissance du nombre de chevaux c'est
pas pour réduire la population comme
c'est prévu aujourd'hui et voici dans
les fait les chevaux qui ont vraiment
été retirés ou éliminés par les méthodes
employées jusqu'ici dans le parc le
rapport du Sénat conclut que le tir
aérien dans des conditions strictes est
l'option de gestion la plus humaine est
la plus
efficace
un autre point de débat est ce que
deviennent ensuite les carcasses des
chevaux abattus la ministre de
l'Environnement a annoncé que la plupart
resterait sur place mais qu'elle serait
éloigné des plans d'eau ou des endroits
les plus fréquentés on l'a compris c'est
un débat ancien parfois même violent qui
continue d'animer l'Australie d'un côté
les défenseurs des chevaux militent
contre un traitement qu'il trouve
inhumain
de l'utre des défenseurs du parc et
plusieurs universités défendent cette
solution comme la moins pire pour
essayer de protéger la biodiversité
locale
[Musique]
j'espère que cette épisode de la grande
explication vous aura intéressé ce thème
il est un peu dur mais je trouvais
intéressant d'essayer de comprendre les
tenants et les aboutissants un peu plus
loin que juste les titre d'article et
vous que pensez-vous de ce débat ça
m'intéresse de le savoir dans les
commentaires il y a une dernière chose
que je voulais vous dire en travaillant
sur ce sujet je suis tombé plusieurs
fois sur ce poème the man from snowy
River qui a été écrit à la fin du 19e
siècle bon littéralement ça veut dire
l'homme de la rivière en neigée et
apparemment c'est l'un des poèmes les
plus connus en Australie il a même été
adapté en film et j'ai découvert
justement que c'est l'un des éléments
qui a contribué à forger l'image des
chevaux
deusco ce poème si j'essaie de traduire
il dit par exemple sur la colline sombre
et lointaine les chevaux sauvages
courent encore avec l'homme de snowy
River à leur trousse un grand merci à
toutes les équipes de brut qui ont
contribué à cet épisode nous on se
retrouve dimanche prochain vers 11h pour
un nouvel épisode de la grande
explication et je vous dis à
bientôt